um the jets as you said earlier it's
like two number one overall picks so
even though the jets didn't end up with
the first first overall pick they had
the second first overall pick and there
was a report a few weeks back that they
were going to decide what to do with sam
darnold after they know what they think
of the incoming quarterback class well
apparently peter they've come to the
conclusion that they like their options
because joe douglas this week addressing
the question of whether he'll talk to
anyone who may call about sam darnold
the third overall pick in 2018 here's
douglas
i i will answer the call um you know if
it's made and so um
you know
as it pertains to sam i mean i like i
said sam sam's a we think a dynamic
player in this league um with
unbelievable talent and who's really
really
um
has a chance to
to really hit his outstanding potential
moving forward but um you know
like like i've said earlier um if calls
are made i i will i will answer them
i said this yesterday you know it's not
quite the same as taking a for sale sign
and a mallet and banging it into the
yard but it's pretty damn close and i
think there are teams out there
interested in sam darnold and because
the jets essentially control the board
post trevor lawrence they don't need to
be coy about it i think that you try to
move darnold
at a time when maximum teams are trying
to figure out what they're going to do
at quarterback once teams start making
their plans your market for darnold may
dry up peter
you know here's the way joe douglas i'm
sure is thinking of this
the market uh for that second pick in
the draft i think minimum minimum
would be the eighth or ninth pick
depending on whether denver carolina
would want to come up
for that eighth or ninth pick plus a one
next year plus a two either this year or
next year now just imagine if the new
york jets did that mike
and imagine if they were sitting there
let's say they would trade with carolina
that would leave them with the eighth
pick this year
the 23rd pick this year
two twos
and then next year
uh
three ones
in the draft and so to me that is one of
these things when you start thinking
about it and you start thinking about
how significant
and the and the wheels that are turning
right now in joe douglas's brain
where he is looking at a roster that
needs to be overhauled okay
and
if you like sam darnold well enough if
you do
then
you could build around sam darnold for
one more year
and let's say mike at the end of this
year
you don't like what you see
then you've got three ones
next year potentially
or
if you were if you were to take one of
the extra ones next year you would have
either two or three ones
next year
in which to solve your quarterback
problem and think about it this way if
if darnold doesn't work out and the jets
stink this year they're gonna have
another top ten pick next year so it's
not gonna be out of the realm of
possibility that the jets could just put
off the sam darnold decision for one
year
and have a lot of first-round picks to
eventually get the quarterback they want
two things to remember about that though
may 3rd is the deadline for exercising
the fifth year option on 2018
first-round picks and this is the first
time that that 50-year option becomes
fully guaranteed when exercised not just
in injury guaranteed that's why you
don't do it
that your body but you're so you're but
but but then you you then you you're
kicking the cam with darnold into free
agency like the bears did with mitchell
trubisky if you don't pick up the option
so you're giving him one more year and
if you like it and the bears
i don't disagree with that but i'm
saying if you're the jets
and you're thinking all right we'll
trade out the number two spot we won't
get zach wilson we'll keep sam darnold
and we won't pick up the option
and let's see how he does oh he was
great now we got to use the franchise
tag to keep him around her we got to
sign and do a much bigger deal than we
would have had to it's just a factor to
consider and and sims
this gets back to his
belief in zack wilson he is a firm
believer that the jets should sprint to
the podium with zach wilson's name on a
card and trade sam darnold and do it you
know
just clear the book sam darnold see you
later we love you we tried you know they
gave up three second round picks to go
from six to three to get him
three years ago they're trying to find
their next joe namath that's the
question
i think we've seen enough of sam darnold
to know he's not gonna be
a short list true franchise quarterback
at any point in his career
but zach wilson could be and i think if
i'm the jets if i'm ownership of that
team and if i've been trying to to sell
psls and tickets and suites and they're
always lagging behind the giants in that
market this is their chance to go all in
with a guy that that could be great and
uh i i just
you know you you they they floated and
they floundered and it's been 50 years i
i think that that uh they just need to
say let's get what we can for sam
darnold and let's get ready to take zach
wilson and the worst case scenario is
the jaguars taken we'll have trevor
lawrence
here's a question for you mike what's
the market for sam darnold
is it
the 49ers second round pick
is it
new orleans
second and fourth
i mean what uh
i i would i i would think i would think
that the market for sam darnold
uh if i were guessing would be somewhere
around
the 35th to 45th pick in the draft this
year
i don't disagree with that because what
did the cardinals get for josh rose and
they got a second round pick
from the miami dolphins and uh darnold
at least
has shown he can he can play can he play
at a high level
well who knows and look
maybe maybe he'll shock us all and he'll
become a true franchise quarterback
somewhere but i think based on what
we've seen so far yeah second round pick
seems fair and see then the question
becomes because there's two windows for
the jets one
is move him now while teams are figuring
out their plans but
the second window is for the teams whose
plan is we're going to draft a guy
if they don't get the guy they want in
round one
then in that 18 hours you have between
the end of round one and the start of
round two that's your opportunity
to sell sam darnold for a second round
pick so
i see those two spots the jets have to
decide how they want to do it
you're exactly right anybody who would
say that okay the jets have until
thursday night april whatever it is 29
um you know at 8 p.m eastern to make
that trade that's not true they have
till friday night
uh whatever 6 p.m 7 p.m eastern whatever
time that is uh to make that pick
because
i look i'm not saying it's impossible
but i doubt that they're gonna get a one
for sam darnold even a low one and so to
me i i kind of look at it mike like
you know they have until about april
30th to make this decision
and i doubt they're gonna wait that long
because clearly
uh you know if they do end up choosing
zach wilson then you know the auction
for sam darnold is on
you know the problem with have too many
options is you eventually got to make a
decision and for the jets the options
are trade sam darnold and take zach
wilson or
see what kind of of haul of picks and
players someone will offer to come get
zach wilson and keep sam darnold and uh
yeah it's not going to be easy for the
jets but if they decide they love zach
wilson again get your franchise
quarterback while you can and and if for
some reason zack wilson doesn't work out
i said the same thing about sam darnold
three years ago you'll be back in
position
before you know it to try to get another
franchise quarterback at the top of the
draft the problem is you may have a new
head coach and a new gm but from an
organizational standpoint you'll be back
and you'll have another shot and now
that woody johnson's back and
christopher johnson is working with him
i'd like to think these guys understand
the value of a true franchise
quarterback to an organization and uh
and let's not let's not overlook the
reality that even though owners
for the most part other than jerry jones
desperately want to create the
impression they don't meddle
when it's time to make that kind of a
pick
they have a way peter of making their
preferences known
there's no there's no way
that
joe douglas or
you know george payton or
scott fitter slash matt rule
there's no way that they're making a
decision like that without the owner
being involved it's just it's just not
going to happen now is the owner going
to dictate it i don't believe so i mean
in carolina maybe more than those other
places but
uh you know in my opinion and in denver
you have to look at the owner's
representative it was joe ellis
um but i really think that that the
owner in all three places or in in any
one of these places for a franchise
altering decision like that
you've got to get the owner involved and
explain to him
why you're doing this you do not make
that decision in a vacuum
billionaire's privilege
allows you to never have to dictate
anything
all you have to say is
if you're woody johnson i really like
zack wilson and if the people who you've
hired to work for you are smart they'll
know what you're saying
because you never have to dirty your
hands with telling people exactly what
they must do if they're smart they'll
know from reading the boss well boss
wants can i give you one can i give you
one exception there okay do you remember
in 1996 mike
when uh there's a new franchise in
baltimore
and art model is the owner
and he's given ozzie newsom the control
of his draft room and art modell says to
him for days before this i love lawrence
phillips we need a star we need a
running back we need a great player i
love lawrence phillips and ozzie newsom
said well i appreciate that but you've
given me control over the draft and i
love jonathan ogden
and so even that day
art model still wanted lawrence phillips
ozzy newsome picked jonathan ogden and
then later in the round obviously uh he
picked ray lewis it's probably the
greatest single round that a general
manager even though he didn't have that
title at that point that uh that a guy
who ran a draft uh uh you could argue
that that's the best round that a guy's
ever had you know and he did it by going
against the owner but
that was a different
time and a different place
because
so often
people had to argue art model out of
decisions because as one long time
employee of the franchise once told me
the way art works is
ready fire aim
um
you know so so sometimes you had to do
things
to counter
his base instincts and most often those
times turned out to be good for the
franchise
well and that's the key because if it
hadn't and if lawrence phillips had
become emmett smith or barry sanders or
walter payton and jonathan ogden hadn't
worked out art model never would have
let ozzy newsome hear the end of it and
you know the flip side of that is the
team that
that
became the browns after the browns
became the ravens jimmy haslam and the
johnny manziel thing from 2014 clearly a
jimmy haslam pick that exploded in the
franchise's face and took them years to
recover from although fortunately for
them they finally have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports